or at the third installment of a CGI
animation for families this could be
good could be crap Madagascar 3 are so
in Madagascar 3 we're joined once again
by Alex the lion and his friends and
they all want to get back to New York to
the zoo you know her life is comfortable
and to do that they hop on a circus
train so they can hitch a ride to get to
America unseen by Cruella Deville who
works for the animal control agencies
chick looks just like Corolla de Ville -
the weird hair and when this movie
started out I was like this movie is on
the fast track to becoming a generic
animation then when they get on the
circus train it really picked up why
well the movie focused itself but mostly
because of that rushing tiger that dude
was the best he was the backbone of the
entire movie he made this movie that's
right the Russians made Erica this guy
was the heart of the movie he had the
damage he's the reason everyone in this
circus kind of sucks now he was the
story I was invested in he made me like
this movie and after that you have some
fun comedy some quirky characters that I
really liked a predictable story arc
yeah you're like okay this is when this
is gonna happen alright this is when
this is gonna happen up the movies not
going to resolve yet because this hasn't
happened but I enjoyed it I got invested
in the movie and dammit I ended up
liking it good comedic timing - those
penguins are the best and they say
really subtle things you're like right
that's that's really funny the other
characters were funny - I like the
bizarre romance between the bear and the
Lemur it cracked me up I bought it more
than most romances in movies yeah these
romances and movies can be this one it
was all right in my book be it silly
yeah silly that's the word for it you
almost feel like the corolla de ville
character is pretty unnecessary she had
her role to play to make the predictable
story art come out where you know when
they have to hit their lowest low it has
to happen in a movie like this other
than that she's really insignificant in
the broad spectrum of the movie
everything you're invested in has
nothing to do with her and in the end
had a really good message about life I
don't always require that movies like
this it's like when gold falls from the
sky I don't expect it to happen what it
does I'm not gonna argue it in fact I'm
probably gonna like it it had a good
message about not hanging on to the Past
liking what you have now let the past be
the past it's okay to move on in fact
it's probably better to remember the
past the way you like it rather than to
go back and find out it's not quite as
good as you remember I like that the
movie got major points from that I
say Madagascar 3 is a surprisingly funny
and good time no alcohol required if you
take your kids at this movie they will
like the entire movie you'll like from
about 15 minutes in on Aarseth
Madagascar movies what's your favorite
Madagascar movie I can ask that because
there's three of them now whatever it
may be
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]